is reportedly putting off his broadcast
career at Fox because he wants to try
stand up I want Tom Brady to stand up so
badly everyone thinks the wrong thing
about Tom Brady's stand-up career
imagine Tom Brady coming on stage with a
[__] cigarette dangling out of his
mouth being like I hate my ex-wife so
goddamn money you guys you guys ever
tongue kissed your son
what's up with that or imagine Tom Brady
walking up on the stage with a [__]
with a number 12 Jersey on being like
let me tell you something about trans
people like it would be amazing to see
Tom Brady being like bad edgy open micro
I would love it so much what if Tom
Brady came out with like a trunk full of
props
take him on the road with me I would
open for Tom Brady this is uh
uh well it's not all the way inflated
hilarious I would I would either see Tom
Brady try to do stand up than to see uh
Aaron Rodgers do stand up and I
guarantee I guarantee Aaron Rodgers has
a tight to win it he does in the dark
for his friends